STAGGERING REPORTS OF JOB LOSSES
AGAIN DURING THE LOCKDOWN COMING
UP.
FIRST TONIGHT BREAKING THE FBI’S
NOW SAYS AN ARMED ATTACK ON A
NAVAL AIR BASE IN TEXAS THIS
MORNING WITH TERRORISM.
WHAT APPEARS TO BE THE SECOND
ISLAMIC RADICAL ATTACK TARGETING
A U.S. MILITARY BASE IN RECENT
MONTHS.
THE SUSPECT WAS KILLED AND ONE
MEMBER OF THE SECURITY TEAM THAT
STOPPED HIM WAS INJURED.
JENNIFER GRIFFIN IS AT THE
PENTAGON WITH THE BREAKING
DETAILS TONIGHT.
GOOD EVENING JENNIFER.
>> IT’S THE SECOND TERRORIST
ATTACK ON A NAVY BASE IN THE
UNITED STATES SINCE DECEMBER.
THIS MORNING AT NAVAL AIR
STATION CORPUS CHRISTI AND TEXAS
A CAR CAME SPEEDING THROUGH A
GATE WHICH TRIGGERED VEHICLE
BARRIERS TO DEPLOY AND STOP THE
CAR.
THE DRIVER BEGAN SHOOTING
INJURING A SECURITY GUARD.
THE SAILOR WAS WEARING A
BULLETPROOF VEST AND HAS SINCE
BEEN RELEASED FROM THE HOSPITAL.
THE SUSPECT WAS REPORTEDLY AN
ARAB MAN AND WAS SHOT AND KILLED
DURING THE ATTACK.
>> WE HAVE DETERMINED THAT THE
INCIDENT THIS MORNING AT
CORPUS CHRISTI IS TERRORISM
RELATED AND THE SCENE IS STILL
BEING PROCESSED.
WE MAY HAVE A POTENTIAL SECOND
RELATED PERSON OF INTEREST AT
LARGE IN THE COMMUNITY BUT WE
WOULD ENCOURAGE THE PUBLIC TO
REMAIN CALM.
AND IF YOU SEE SOMETHING, SAY
SOMETHING.
>> TODAY’S ATTACK COMES JUST
MONTHS AFTER A SAUDI PILOT IN
TRAINING WENT ON A RAMPAGE
KILLING THREE SERVICE MEMBERS IN
PENSACOLA, FLORIDA.
ON MONDAY THE FBI AND
ATTORNEY GENERAL WILLIAM BARR
HELD A PRESS CONFERENCE TO
ANNOUNCE THAT THE SAUDI PILOT
WHO WENT ON THE SHOOTING SPREE
AT THE NAVAL AIR STATION IN
PENSACOLA HAD BEEN IN TOUCH WITH
AN AL QAEDA LEADER IN YEMEN,
WHICH THE FBI LEARNED AFTER
CRACKING THE ENCRYPTION ON THE
SHOOTER’S iPHONE.
THE AL QAEDA IN THE ARABIAN
PENINSULA LEADER IN CONTACT WITH
THE SAUDI PILOT WAS ABDULLAH AL
MALACHI.
WE HAVE SINCE LEARNED THAT THE
HANDLER WAS KILLED IN U.S.-LED
OPERATION AND IT’S NOT CLEAR IF
TODAY’S ATTACK IN TEXAS IS
LINKED.
SOURCES TELL FOX THE SHOOTER IN
TEXAS TODAY HAD LOTS OF
AMMUNITION AND IT TOOK ABOUT
FIVE HOURS TO GET THE BODY
BECAUSE LOCAL AUTHORITIES
THOUGHT HE MIGHT HAVE BEEN